[Musik]
Reportage über Endometriose seit einige
Kommentare und ich Filme Kommentaren
Betroffene ihre Geschichte verzählt das
auf die einzige schlimm weil es ganz
viel geht wo es gleich geht
auf die andere Seite
zum Beispiel geschrieben meine Diagnose
habe ich durch die OP vor knapp zehn
Jahren bestätigt bekommen damals wurde
ich von der Tante meines Mannes auf die
Erkrankung aufmerksam gemacht
um das wurde mir auch schon gekündigt
wegen zehn Fehltagen in einem ganzen
Jahr ja aber die Kommentare sich
bestätigt dass oft die Krankheit lange
nicht erkennt wie die dem Fall ist sogar
nicht von einem Arzt oder von der Ärztin
auf die Krankheit aufmerksam gemacht
wurde sondern aus dem privaten Umfeld
und was ich auch mega krass finde ist
dass der der Person war gezeigt
Rachel schreibt ich habe auch Ende und
bin immer froh mehr in den Medien
darüber zu sehen zu hören
alle sagen das Schweizer ihnen lange
brauchen bis eine gute Beziehung
stattfindet und man wirklich tiefe
Sachen besprechen kann beim Endo ist das
überhaupt nicht so das schönste vor
allem finde ich die Offenheit
Verständnis und Support welche wir alle
miteinander haben ich als wie schön
gefunden dass sie in der Krankheit auch
bis schönes positives abgewöhnen nämlich
dass sie sich mit anderen Betroffenen
und würde mich auch freuen wenn das da
in der Kommentar so wieder geführt wird
denn nennt sich auspark meldet wo nicht
endometriol sind aber in andere
chronische Krankheit und wo sich
trotzdem bestätigt fühlten mit dem Film
weil sie nämlich auch zum Beispiel lange
sind oder sehr starke Schmerzen können
zum Beispiel der Andi schreibt ich als
chronischer Migräniker Fülle bei diesen
Beitrag richtig mit so unglaublich viele
Parallelen Tatsache Schmerzen gehen an
niemandem spurlos vorbei viel Kraft euch
allen ein Kommentar wo ich von der andus
17/17 ist sie dass sie selber
Endometriose
haben die Betroffenen verschiedene
Pillen probiert oder überhaupt die Pille
probiert dafür ich hoffe alle
Betroffenen finden etwas das Ihnen hilft
liebe Grüße
und eine wo da immer wieder gefallen
ganz viel unterschiedliche andere
probiert die Einzelverträge sind die
anderen nicht ich glaube das ist ein
bisschen individuell
die ganz Thematik rund um Pille hat aber
auch noch in andere Kommentar
stattgefunden die Diskussion und darum
würde ich sehr gerne mit dem
Endometriose Spezialisten über das Thema
reden und im anuspaar André frohgestellt
ich kann ihn für das in Zürich treffen
bei Kommentaren
Endometriose nimmt so hat zum Beispiel
noch geschrieben es ist keine normale
Pille die einem zur Therapie verschieben
wird sondern hochdosierte Gestagene
diese lösen bei den meisten Patientinnen
starke Nebenwirkungen aus leider ist
noch immer nicht erwiesen dass es die
endoherde eindämmt wie ist das ist das
ein herkömmlichen Pillen oder ist das
ein spezielle also sowohl als auch ich
mit sogenannten konventionellen
die menstruationsbeschwerde
das sind aber effektive
gedächt man einfach gesehen
können
die wirksam Substanz ist und darum ist
man in der Vorstellung
einfach sehr spezifisch auf die
schlimmhütte wirkt und das sehr
atrophisieren wird also das
regelrechtigen müssen wir schon sagen
also was sehr häufig jetzt speziell mit
der Gäste gehen
ohne effektiv Güte
wieder so ungefähr 5% von der Freude
dass psychisch zum Training zugute
Hamburg
wissenschaftlich analysierte wird es
sich mal nichtsprachige
das aber vor allem junge urbane Gürtels
gebildete Freude ganz große
dich interessiert wieso ist der das
er beachtlichen
Informationen wirklich über Social Media
Kanälen
und das habe ich ein Witz erschreckt
dass er gesehen
oder und mir ist aber wirklich
proaktivwirkungen ganz anders
[Musik]
proaktiv wirklich die
präparaturvorstellung was hält der
zerborten und benefit aber Roy
unmögliche nach Thailand das sollte
heißen
dann eine Bauchspiegelung aus Diagnostik
wirklich empfohlen wird
die Fragen
von der von der Endometriose Geschichte
und das hat man schon mit der Vakuum
die Modalität
bewusstseinament da ist Gott sei Dank
dass man einfach wirklich Tradition
würden die probieren und wenn die liegt
Aussprachen
und wenn die Schmerzen
Operation oder man möchte vorstellen das
sind Operationen Vollnarkose und wenn es
nicht primär brüht ist das sicher schon
mal erfordern
von der Freude hinter die Diagnose
endlich
operativ
Operationen sind meistens sinnvoll oder
müssen wir wirklich dem Fall wenn
schwarze
Grund oder wenn Kinderwunsch im
Vordergrund steht oder beim
hormonellänge unerfüllte schinderlu also
Kinderlosigkeit hat das ist sicherlich
in Migration und bei deiner schwere
delfinfiltrierende Formel wo wirklich
Organ drunter liegen also wenn es
enttäuscht der nur Sie Ihre vom
hornlager vom dornuntersuchung das sind
sicherlich zwingend die
operationsgründen wichtig finde ich aber
zu erwähnen dass es Frauen gibt die
Endometriose haben aber keinerlei
Beschwerden wenn du Endometriose hat
1000 Gesichter sie sind ja im
Vorgespräch schon erwähnt dass es ein
chamäleonkrankheit ist
für das Auto der lange Diagnose zieht ja
definitiv und aber also wenn man
Endometriose quasi per türvoll sieht im
Rahmen
blinddarnen
und aber Sandra ist schon so durch das
so ganz unterschiedlich manifestiert um
einfach zum Teil
also wenn ihr das an je nachdem wenn du
es am 2 Fall hält deren
Schulterschmerzen
über dieses Thema man mich nimmt es noch
wunderbar was genau dann operiert wird
also wie muss man sich seine OP
vorstellen im oberwiegenden
das sind 5 mm Rezessionen und das
natürlich
die Erholungs zieht postoperativ
wirklich
toll und das passiert perfekt
und lange Stil sieht massive verbesser
gekauft
[Musik]
bis 50% von der Freude
unter Umständen mit Problemen kennen da
in der spontanen stieg von der
Schwangerschaft machen
wenn man sich nicht an
ob das Thema in der Mitte wirklich
angesprochen wurde oder nicht
Vorwurf machen will will dass sich das
so ist unterschiedlich
das präsentiert sich so unterschiedlich
und dass man da aber vielleicht nicht
primär anändern
Betroffene
also absolute das ist XIV
Frage wenn ihr noch mehr Fragen mit
Kommentar schreiben